[Music]
so in ridiculous enrollment news
submitted by mutter gels preps he is and
here sorry we do have his boss I don't
want to put that in my mouth though
you'd smell it though I don't think
you've ever watched that once I don't
think so I think [ __ ] goes in and out
of his mouth that mouth harp that's
right here no I will pick it up the show
oh there you go you're both the same guy
looks like a tweezer but I'm not looking
I'm not going to I thought you were down
I don't know how to play it Oh God for
you you had a harder you try bigger I
write them down found bound so top
schools in China are testing parents for
their IQ ancestors grades and obesity
for the child enrollment ancestors great
yet great like lineage yeah we don't
want a chance of dumb fatties bro that's
a definite oh well my kids are [ __ ]
that's how competitive it is over there
where your grades and your scores aren't
enough they need to know your parent
what does your weight have to do with
your intelligence so they're saying that
fat parents don't have any discipline
yeah they don't have discipline over
we're dating that's what they said okay
first of all god that's so true we'll
have this one over ourselves back
discipline [ __ ] out of my kid I know
that's different
could I just ate a banana that tastes
like ass but because I repaid to ate the
whole thing
so I guess it's not so much truth she
was completely unripe your dream I don't
know
yeah Jerry Allen obesity man I don't be
silly [ __ ] you know what though food is
a drug just to let y'all know in the
States
food is a drug we are addicted to that
[ __ ] it's so hard to kill feel sorry for
me the same way you feel sorry for
crying attics
sometimes an Oriole just makes you feel
good about yourself always it does hold
up in ones too are like golden are of
him you have a very big penguin huh you
had a birthday cake me I don't like them
we're [ __ ] recognized you say every
not every day like one thing everything
huh but why why would I make it so that
means there's an extra one there for you
to purchase now I say he to box of
cookies and she tried a connection I got
enough
I got enough over here but I need to
know the people around me are smart
enough I'd like the right brand
I saw a brand goody well you know in
recent news Oreo was trying to look for
a new flavor right now oh this they
don't even need to ask people for that
that's a whole bunch of options out
there they eat the creative [ __ ]
dominance on the flavors I would love to
have a pork chop this later
but the girls in life I don't like to
talk to anyway we're going to stretch up
here we're talking about schools and so
I leave prove their point yeah
one [ __ ] word [ __ ] Ruby goddamnit
we have no discipline we go discipline
it's in four minutes that we've got my
Oreos what I'll [ __ ] the droppage [ __ ]
okay fine you got upset
oh [ __ ] well look at that huh alright if
you did a good job you can't have any
low-fat even there yeah so they're
saying that at least two private schools
in Shanghai have been admonished by
sorry B's authorities for testing
parents and carrying out intrusive
surveys yeah I don't like that [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] prejudge my kid because I
made poor choices with my god yep what
what about the fact that they're testing
your ancestor [ __ ] you don't you can't
have that talking [ __ ] about my [ __ ]
dead people behind me and [ __ ] oh no
[ __ ] what they did I don't be [ __ ]
judging my kids are what the problemo is
though is that what we're thinking we're
viewing it from the American perspective
of like this is a public school and I
have a right to be after school from
their perspective they could be like the
Harvard of the country so they are all
ready way over supply so they're like
well how do I compare 5,000 4.0 I don't
know let's take it up so you just apply
to that school if you don't want to
comply but you can't have to but I can
say limited but I can see where they're
coming from it's so good point yeah
that's exactly why so how else do you
how do you there's like 20,000 kids with
straight A's nice how do you come how do
you compare those so I wouldn't because
there's plenty of situations with dumb
parents smart kid yeah so what is
checking them going to do Chinese people
understand that he was in their dumb mmm
you would have to just apply to another
school that's right there's a lot of
dumb parents more kids yeah what the
[ __ ] that's true but there are no fat
parents market Oh corner this is even
more true God Jesus yeah no one has to
apply to these schools yeah no one
should but the problem is I think
probably they're so sought after
everyone's gonna do it anyways well you
thought yeah exactly be very like pop
pop school so if you wanted to put your
kid in a really top school like how far
do you think you would take the
enrollment like the admission process is
this high school no sorry elementary
what yeah it really depends like if it's
in America I don't give a [ __ ] you don't
have to go to school to be successful
but in a lot of Asian countries it's
completely different in schools
everything were yes we're moving to
America yeah so it's a little bit
different but it was me I would do it
because I my elementary student probably
doesn't want to go to that kind of
[ __ ] school so ain't gonna feel like
he's missing out on anything and if
enough people don't even try to go to
that school room and yeah yeah so how
about trying to go to that donator
school it's so interesting because I'm
trying to think
do we judge other parents when we let's
say you know like there's a parent right
like you know you when you have kids
you're gonna go to the lake the school
conferences you know this little Timmy
which is friends with little Wayne
little Timmy's parents are fat and
slovenly do you judge the parents a
little bit ya know I don't know yeah
this is the thing if I see a obese
parent with an obese child then I just
pan because I know where you got yeah
but if if there's nothing wrong with the
child and the parent is slappy or
whatever and I'm like whatever because I
see it as like not saying I would do
that [ __ ] I'm thinking about like jobs
like it's a proven statistic that people
will hire better looking more fit people
than fat ugly people yeah yeah I mean
has nothing to do with that they're just
human nature though excuse me so I
wonderful even like infants prefer a
good-looking person measures are not a
person and their infant no no I think
people prefer to live in infants okay
they did a study like a legit study they
start crying when they see something
ugly then I start crying ones but they
gravitated more towards the attractive
person no wonder children like me or how
could you saw no it's because I had the
exactly faces in the problems of
development doing it don't fake it
yeah that these schools are really
really really expensive in the fact that
you know China has like so many more
wealthier families coming out of this
country and they're just trying to put
their kids in the very best schools and
even though China doesn't have the
one-child policy anymore a lot of people
are still only having one kid and later
on that one kid is going to be a sole
provider for that family so they're
trying to set them up for like the best
possible future like what they're only
having one kids oh that's good a little
bit too much this is just fact I wish we
had a one-child policy over here or
maybe two child policy 2 3 welcome come
on David make up your mind
don't be good the reason why it's
because I'm a little worried because I
don't want my kid to grow up I want them
to have a sibling maybe - ok - chocolate
your girlfriend pregnant now
and then they'll have a place buddy I
cannot drop - I can't do that [ __ ] I
mean if I had a kid by natl to go in
mine but I ain't ready for that stuff in
awe a little me running around little
[ __ ] piece oh my god I think the [ __ ]
ok I know I know I'm already like what
the funny thing is like I can already
picture how stupid my child is going to
be so Meryl I will have a conversation
right let's just hypothetically speaking
like we get married in the future we
have kids I start getting mad at the
kids
am i this little [ __ ] [ __ ] when it
talks back and go [ __ ] do you think you
are because like it's not born yet what
are you talking about [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
[ __ ] raised them up you should
talking back to me call me back what the
[ __ ] as you like bill calm the [ __ ] down
you're gonna during a defendant really
thank you
that's a problem now you always baby all
that other [ __ ] this I know we talked
about it but I should probably did say
something like that I could make it just
imagine tiny David walking around and
like falling on his face all business
we're getting a divorce
yeah i anything about having kids
Richard um I mean I know I'm going
through there cheated in the future I'll
think about it
how are you so sure yeah sure
oh my god are you so sure Oh use condoms
bro I'll probably have about six or
seven running around right now we just
don't know we walked out looking legit
like you daddy
nine kids you know my dad has strong
genes right I look like my dad oh yeah
yeah my sister and my little brother
that's what our sons and daughters are
going to look like pretty tasty yeah the
same circle eyes my shits off to [ __ ]
compared to this I don't know what the
[ __ ] your kids are going to look like
doing I'm so curious you know I wanna
by your faces in my head to picture this
child so I don't know what the [ __ ] we
do a face loss to our kids in one place
a lot take my brush don't you like that
yeah like I have a half Mexican brother
a half a Nicaraguan brother and then
like a full black sister and all of them
are me ha ha ha ha just different change
in insane but it takes her like a baby
being made right and there's like if you
look into like the super microscope you
see the genes it's like you're dancing
like I'm here move aside money every
month yeah Nicaraguan oh my face
get up it's run crazy oh my nephew looks
just like me - he's half Puerto Rican so
he just but he looks poor again let me
it is something to show us
I want to going on take a news fans hope
you guys like that episode remember to
follow our personal social media and of
course if you want to watch more videos
my go where to go your [ __ ] right
up there
[Music]
you